a Colorado paramedic who died from the
corona virus after volunteering to help
save lives in New York is being
remembered as a hero emotional tributes
were held yesterday as the body of 66
year old Paul Carey was transported home
he had already signed up for another 30
days of service in New York before he
got sick
Jamie yuccas has his story a somber
homecoming Sunday for a man who spent
his life serving others after 30 years
as a firefighter in Aurora Colorado
Paul Carey became a paramedic he didn't
hesitate when asked to join the battle
against coronavirus in New York City
fellow paramedic Royce Davis was he the
type of guy that wanted to run into the
burning building you would not be able
to hold him back that's why Carey came
to New York on April 1st part of a wave
of out-of-state medical staff to assist
the city's overwhelm first responders
often transporting kovat patients from
hospital to hospital less than two weeks
ago he himself became ill before
succumbing to coronavirus last Thursday
as he began his final journey home
New Yorkers lined the streets to pay
tribute powerful respect Mayor Bill de
Blasio says Carey will be among those
honored in a new memorial to medical
workers from around the country who
answered New York's call for help
in a statement Kerry's two sons and four
grandsons say they're at peace knowing
he did what he loved and believed in
right up until the very end what did he
stand for just be humble go help people
doesn't matter what age you are it will
help him for CBS this morning I'm Jamie
yuccas yeah our thanks to Paul Carey for
everything he did for the city in the
state and our condolences to his family